السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله انا قصدت اقعد في الجزء الثاني من
المؤتمر ده في الجزء الخلفي
هناك عندي اسبابي في الحايه دي وحوريه لكم
بعد
شويه انا حاسب انه انا اصغر من انه انا
اجيف في الحته دي واحكي لكم حاجه ممكن زول
يستفيد منها في حياته لانه التجارب الاسي
مرت قبل شويه ا فاجاتني جدا انا سامع
بالحاجات دي ا وكنت بصراحه كده حاسب انه
الموضوع ده ممكن ا يعالج بعض المسائل لكن
الناس لو ما تغيرت في
دواخله ما حيحصل تغيير ل قدام اجتهادات
بالمناسبه سمحه جدا من الناس دي كونهم هم
يعملوا حاجه زي دي دي ما حاجه سهله في
الظروف الصعبه اللي احنا عايشينها حول
العالم مش هنا بس وكونه نجيب الشقيري هنا
عشان يشوف مباد شارع الحوادث مثلا حاجه ما
هينه يا اخوان طيب انا عندي فيديو صغير
مدته
دقيقتين ما اعرف انتم ح تتقبلو ولا لا لكن
حاولوا تسمعوا الحاجه دي وتشوفوها بقلوبكم
ما وعيونكم بس ممكن تعرض الفيديو يا
[موسيقى]
كنترول
you
bel but you will find
that there is
a been there
[موسيقى]
you and when it
can
[موسيقى]
listen andy soon
you out
your everyone plays a
pe
mel and each one of
us it's
[موسيقى]
glorious and you will
know
[موسيقى]
as who
are those around
you to wake
up to the ss that are in their
heart
am we all
creating it's like a
syy just keep
listening and pretty soon
you fig out
your every play a
andel and one of
us
[تصفيق]
glor
it's like a
syy just keep
listening and pry
you
[موسيقى]
يا ريت الناس تكون سمعت الكلام ده
بقلبها كلام بسيط في طرحه لكن معناه كبير
جدا بالمناسبه معنى كيف انت ت تل مع الناس
بروح واحده وما تعيش لنفسك
بس حاول انت مع الزول اخوك صاحبك
مجهوداتكم مع بعض بتعمل لكم سمفونيه جميله
جدا انا لما سمعت الحاجه دي اول مره
بصراحه ما كد معتي قريبه يعني فبكيت جدا
وحسيت بانه انا الخيار اللي انا اخذته في
حياتي في يوم من الايام ما المفروض اندم
عليه لانه ده شكلي في الحياه عامل كده انا
المفروض اعمل الحايه دي ما المفروض افكر
في انه انا اكون زول تاني عشان الناس
بتقول لا لا انت ما تبقى كده عشان انت
حتعمل كده في المستقبل وحتكون كده وكده حس
بالحاجه جواك اول وشوف انت حاب شنو عايز
تكون شنو ونفذ القرار مباشره الحاجه دي
بالمناسبه خطوه صعبه جدا للناس زي ما قلت
لكم في ظل الظروف الصعبه الزول اللي بيقدر
يتغلب على الظروف ويعمل الحاجه اللي هو
عايزها ده انا بعتبره زول موهوب حتى لو
كان ما عنده موهبه من المواهب المعروفه
انا اتخذت قرار انا في ثالثه في السمستر
السادس في كليه علوم التمريض في جامعه
النيلين انه انا اخلي
الجامعه وعلى فكره انا ما اخذت الجامعه
لانه انا زول فاشل انا كننت تاني
الدفعه المستوى الاول المستوى الثاني
المستوى الثالث اناي كان في ب قاعده قدامي
مدا جراني مجره تديني فر كله كله لكن كنت
زول عارف انا داير اصل لشنو في اللحظه ديك
لما وصلت سمستر 6 انا قلت يا اخي انا ما
عايز اكون كده ل باقي حياتي ما عايز اكون
ذول تكنيكال نيرس في مستشفى وشغال من
الصباح لحد مع انه دي وظيفه انسانيه جميله
جدا وانا قاعد احب جدا انه انا اخدم البشر
ح لكن ده ما انا ما الحاجه اللي انا
عايزها ما لانه دي حاجه سمحه وحاجه
انسانيه انا المفروض اذا انت ما اقتنعت
لانه انت عايز تعمل الحاجه دي فتش جواك
عشان تلقى الحاجه اللي انت عايزها شوف انت
عايز تكون شنو ببساطه
شديده طلعت من الجامعه مشيت استوديو بتاع
[موسيقى]
صوت بصراحه كده
فنان
والفنان اسم بالمناسبه كبير ما بسيط واحد
لما يقوللك فنان المفروض ما تزعل تحس
بالفخر لان قاللك انت فنان عندك ذوق
الفنان ذواق تشكيلي ولا كان بيغني ولا كان
بيعزف هو فنان فما المفروض تخ وانا دي
الحيا اللي عملتها يعني مع انه ا الناس
اللي حواليني على الاقل ما وافقوا على الح
ما كانوا رضيان يعني انت دار تعمل شنو
يعني دار تصل لشنو قلت لهم يا اخوان انا
دي حاجه قاعد احبها انتم فاهمين انه انا
بنقل احساسي في اتجاه معين و بيصل للناس
واشوفه في عيونهم دي حاجه انا
بحبها الانترتت هي وظيفه ما هينه حول
العالم انك ترفع عن الناس تسمعهم لحن جميل
تغني لهم وحتى تضحكه دي ما حاجه هنا
بالمناسبه دي حاجه في قمه الصعوبه انك
تطلع زول من مود لمود تاني في
لحظه اتجه في الاتجاه ده وما توقعت النجاح
بصراحه لكن كنت مبسوط وكونك تكون مبسوط دي
اهم حاجه انت مبسوط من الحاجه اللي انت
قاعد تعملها فلو انت انبسطت من الحاجه
اللي انت قاعد تعملها انت ماشي
صح بعد
شويه القبول من الناس حاجه صعبه برضو
والحمد لله رب العالمين الناس قبلت الحاجه
البسيطه ان احنا قدمنا طيب انا ما د اجيف
لحد هنا بس انا حاسي بانه
لو انا ممكن بالمناسبه اقعد قدام ناس
واتكلم واقنع فكره جتني في راسي
كده لحسن الحظ يعني استاذ هاجر الهادي
اتصلت علي تليفون من تلفزيون السودان
قالتلي يا خالد بدون اي مقدمات نحنا دايرك
ججي تقدم لنا برنامج كليب
سودان قلت لها يا اخي انا ما بعرف اصلا
اقدم قت تعال مشيت عملوا لي تست بتاع
صوره
مرتين المرتين كنت بش جدا لكن حسيت بانه
يا اخي ما في حاجه بتخوف يعني معلومات انا
بمشي بنبط بطلعها بسهل للزول اللي قاعد
يشوف ده عشان ثقافته تزيد في في حته
معينه الموضوع مشى والحلقات مشت وكان في
بالمناسبه معوقات كبيره جدا عشان البرنامج
ده
يقيف والتيم كله صبر على الحاجه ديدي لحد
ما الموضوع نجح واسي نحنا في اتاب
المهرجان بتاع الموسم الاول وفي عملين
بالمناسبه من مدني ايرس لو قاعد
هنا العم المرشح انو في
المهان الملخص عشان انا بيتكم
شديد باختصار في لاثه كلمات بس حاول تعمل
في اربعه معلش انا حسابي حاول تعمل الحاجه
اللي انت عايزها و انت بتحبها يز
شكرا
l